Rob Kardashian spotted out for the first  time in months he has the photos the 28  year old standing outside his car the  first full-length photo we've seen of  him in months this after he and his  girlfriend blac chyna returned from an  outing in Beverly Hills and I witnessed  lzt at Rob has been staying with blac  Chyna since he picked her up in Texas  after her arrest in December it was  reported that Rob was diagnosed with  diabetes but blac Chyna's BFF Amber Rose  says China is a healthy influence on raw  Chyna's cooking healthy meals for him  it's just like it's it's a really really  good vibe Rob has been reclusive for  months but we are starting to see more  of him on social media he just joined  snapchat and posted this video rocking a  full beard China followed up with this  Nazi forward warning to Rob's new  snapchat followers you snap in my booth